So I want to be really careful about the segment.
What I want to do is I want to steal man or
make the strongest possible left wing argument
against broad lockdowns and stay at home orders
as a way to deal with Corona virus.
And I want to be really clear.
There are lots of really bad arguments on
the right against Lockdown's.
What would a left wing case against Lockdown's
look like?
That's what I want to answer today.
So as a reminder, bad arguments against Lockdown's
from the right include things like only old
people will die and we don't really need to
worry about that.
That's a bad argument against Lockdown's stay
at home orders or government teary Taraneh
or like Nazis or whatever.
No, that's wrong.
And that is a bad argument against Lockdown's.
The left wants people to be unemployed.
No.
That's a very bad argument against Lockdown's
stay at home orders.
Don't save anyone.
No, that's a bad argument against Lockdown's.
The economy is simply more important than
people's lives.
Or we should be willing to sacrifice grandma
or lockdown's or merely meant to hurt Donald
Trump's reelection chances.
These are all terrible arguments against Lockdown's
and stay at home home orders.
I think you get it.
There are lots of really bad right wing arguments
against stay at home orders.
Let me present maybe a more realistic left
wing case against the full lockdown's that
some places have been doing so on the left.
We recognize as a guiding principle, essentially,
that in American society and an American in
the American economy, it is the working class,
the working poor, the lower middle class blue
collar workers.
It's all these groups who are more vulnerable,
who are more precariously sitting on the edge
between being able to pay for their living
expenses and not.
And they are the first to get the shaft from
our economic system for lack of a better term.
And at the same time, it is those exact people
who are most hurt by broad stay at home orders.
It's not really the white collar workers.
It's not the lawyers.
It's not the people who can work from home.
It's not brand managers and management consultants.
The people most hurt by stay at home orders
are restaurant workers, grocery store employees,
agricultural or agricultural workers, delivery
drivers, people in transportation, Uber and
Lyft, etc., etc., etc..
These are folks who have less power to begin
with in our economy.
They have less of a financial cushion to get
through a calamity and who either lose their
jobs or have to work in dangerous conditions
or see their hours reduced without extra pay.
Thanks to the stay at home orders.
So if we think about who is most hurt by a
broad lockdown, it's the very people that
we on the left have prioritized, as it should
be, because they are the most taken advantage
of now.
At the same time, even though we've had broad
stay at home orders in many places, we've
completely failed to actually protect the
people most at risk.
Older folks.
People in nursing homes.
Long-Term Care Facilities.
Here in Massachusetts, at one point, half
of all deaths were in nursing homes.
The average age of death here in Massachusetts
as of yesterday is 82 years of age.
I don't I think I assume that's median.
I'm not sure how it's been calculated, but
it's been widely reported by health authorities.
Eighty two is the average age of death.
We have failed to protect nursing homes and
this is happening nationally.
There are some states I told you yesterday,
the day before even hiding.
Nursing home deaths, which over understates
the problem even more.
We've not done enough testing, which from
day one would have been a fantastic way to
identify more cases, quickly isolate people.
We didn't invest in fever clinics, which is
a colloquial term, basically places for people
who have the disease but are not super sick
that they need to be in a hospital.
Places to isolate like South Korea has done
while they recover.
So if you want to make a left wing case against
Broad Lockdown's, the argument would be we
could have skipped such a broad lockdown,
we could have stayed much more open in terms
of restaurants and some other places.
Certainly large sporting events, concerts
had to be canceled, but we could have kept
more stuff open, could have kept it open with
mandatory masks.
We could have much earlier spent way more
money on safeguarding older folks, long term
care, nursing home facilities and way more
money should have been spent early on testing
from the beginning.
So this is not so much about blame.
I mean, you know, there's blame to go around.
The federal government has a huge amount of
blame.
State governments have failed in many cases
to protect older populations.
This particular segment is not about blame.
We know there's plenty to go around, but there
are things that could have been done.
Now, I want to be really clear.
I'm not falling for this entire children and
young people aren't affected by the virus.
We are seeing children affected to some degree.
Some with a cow calici.
He like illness.
We are seeing, you know, younger adults to
some degree affected.
But the mortality rate for people under 65,
particularly those without preexisting conditions
or comorbidities, is infinitesimally small.
And, you know, we hear about healthy 42 year
old died of corona virus.
Yeah, but understand that those numbers are
close to zero.
And this is not like the flu in total.
But sometimes you will get an unexplained
death from the flu in a young, healthy person.
Sometimes it will happen.
It is a tiny, tiny fraction.
So isolation stay at home for older folks.
Of course, way more testing, of course.
Fever clinics for sick people, of course,
closed large events, of course, masks, et
cetera.
But there is a case that one could make that
we could have if we were more competently
led at the beginning, we could have kept more
things open in a way that would have directly
helped the most vulnerable workers in the
economy while changing the total risk.
Very little.
We could have avoided a lot of economic destruction.
Now, that is me still manning a left wing
case against Lockdown's.
Do I literally believe it 100 percent?
Of course not.
One example.
Lots of younger people live with older people.
So if you want to keep the young restaurant
worker employed, but there are grandparents
safe and they live together.
How do you do it?
Right.
So it doesn't literally work in all cases.
But I want to hear your thoughts.
And the point that I'm making is left wing
skepticism of a total and complete stay at
home is okay.
The right wing skepticism and the tax on the
guidelines are ridiculous.
And they're wrong and they're laughable.
There is a sensible conversation to have about
how it could have been handled differently,
and it may be relevant for when Wave two happens
if we haven't a break between wave one and
wave two.
But we've got to actually think it through.
And that's what I'm trying to do with you
right here.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember, we have a daily our podcast that
you can get on iTunes, Stitcher, Google Play
and all of your favorite podcast apps.
Make sure to sign up for it.
And let me know your thoughts on Twitter where
I am at
David Pakman.